[Music]
in France they are mourning the worst
peacetime attacks since World War two it
is the deadliest outburst of terror in
Europe since the Madrid bombings a
decade ago more than a hundred and
twenty people killed and over 350
injured in just a few hours of carnage
multiple acts of barbarity which have
rocked Paris this was the first
indication that a night of terror had
begun
ten minutes later a second explosion
outside there'd been two suicide
bombings at separate gates of the stab
de France the game carried on all the
way to night minutes as far as we were
aware it was even though we were getting
news reports we thought it was something
trivial we thought it was a hoax
something had gone wrong we didn't the
match continued it was only after full
time and a third explosion outside that
people started to leave the France and
Germany friendly the three suicide
bombers had failed to deliver the mass
casualties amongst fans they'd hoped for
one man caught by flying shrapnel told
how his mobile phone had saved his life
I was crossing the road and there was an
explosion everything went up in flames
I felt the reverberations I fell down
here's the phone that took the impact
and it saved me some spectators flooded
onto the open space of the pitch amidst
the specter of an increasingly
terrifying night seemingly the only safe
place they were prepared to go the
famous faces of the two sides watched TV
monitors scarcely able to believe what
was happening the German team were
advised to stay at the stadium overnight
fearful of travelling to their hotel
shortly afterwards francois hollande was
driven away to a secure location by now
it was clear something very serious was
unfolding and Paris was in the grip of
multiple coordinated attacks five miles
away the batterer clan theater was
packed with young music fans we were by
the bar so he heard firecrackers or what
we thought with firecrackers we turned
around and I saw two young men and there
were older than 25 with Kalashnikovs
they told us to lie down there was one
who kept gesturing for us to get down we
all lay down the whole room lay down
I was completely under other people and
they kept shooting but they would stop
from time to time the concert had
started about half an hour before we
heard firecracker noises and we turned
around and saw two young people two
young people well we were a bit of far
away so two people was machine guns
firing into the crowd so we all laid on
the ground there was panic screams shots
continued to be fired at the right of
the stage a door was opened and we all
rushed there we got stuck there it was
leading to a staircase we got stuck into
a staircase for five to ten minutes
people were trying to force some doors
open but the doors only led to dressing
rooms and green rooms
Elite police units take up their
positions outside the hall inside the
attackers were yelling this is for Syria
it's the fault of your president with
the 1500 seat venue a sellout the horror
of a hostage situation was starting to
take hold this footage shows the back of
the theater and the desperate efforts of
Santa flea trying to climb from 1st and
2nd floor windows
air kiss kiss faster this injured man
got out through a back door
cvilikas key sparser what's happening
shouts someone
[Music]
others also make it to safety dozens
more would not be so lucky
as it became clear the terrorists had
started killing hostages elite police
units tried to move in they were
repeatedly pushed back by the gunmen
one woman who managed to escape his
theme being rushed away her life safe
for several hours the sound of gunfire
could be heard until this one after the
other two of the attackers blew
themselves up with suicide belts a third
was killed by security forces
finally the survivors were able to walk
free at this one venue alone more than
80 people lost their lives
at such a large concert hall the gunman
secured their ambition for mass
casualties this was by far the highest
number of people killed in a single
location on a night of coordinated
attacks worst days for the people coming
out of the butter claimed injury shock
because many people was went out of the
of the place and that's what I
experienced in the street what was the
hardest because I met a lot of people
who shocked blood and bloody injury and
when I heard about the first news that
it was only 1015 people killed I told
everybody you don't even realize what's
happening inside because I heard about
the people going out and they told needs
to slaughter inside there they're
shooting everybody inside I knew it from
the beginning because I was very close
the Bataclan had been full of mostly
young people by a twist of fate one
woman told us how she escaped the siege
just as it was beginning since the
second before the shooting I was just
next to the bed at home just like two
steps and they start shooting so I was
like okay thanks God I'm not in the bed
at home but just remember the people so
I saw the people just sitting by the
clown just laughing and drinking I was
like oh she's cute okay
now they're probably they're actually so
it wasn't just high-profile venues which
came under attack neighborhood bars and
restaurants were also targeted famed for
its cafe culture many Parisians were
sitting ducks
this footage gives you a sense of what
the people of Paris went through on
Friday night having to tend to the
injured on pavements the third team of
gunmen randomly roamed the city shooting
in numerous locations
in one restaurant alone
19 people were killed at another a
gunman used an automatic weapon to shoot
through windows I heard some noise when
I was at the Bistro which is where I
work I got out I started running I was
looking for where the sound was coming
from I figured out it was coming from
the carry on the Pittock ambush I
arrived at the scene and there were lots
of dead bodies on the ground
lots of dead bodies lots of dead bodies
when Parisians woke up to the reality of
their Friday night of terror there was a
sense of disbelief one man told how he
should have been watching football in
the carrion bar instead he saw the
shootings unfold from his daughter's
apartment I saw all these men running
and all the direction people just in
front here under the table and people
should know
are they solo
it's like world what crazy these people
must not win
they make so many problems all over the
world we must be together
they kill our child innocent people
18:20 don't sit here during three hours
of terror in a series of coordinated
attacks three groups of gunmen ran amok
across Paris amongst the huge crowd at
the Bataclan theater were two friends
from Scotland arriving back at Edinburgh
Airport they told Sky News how they
feared they might die we were just at
the corner we arrived just after a got
those the funds may up with some friends
they hunt he figures who enjoying the
concert and then had what thought was
like well I thought the firecrackers for
hanging this could right at the front
turned around
[Music]
gunfire and we needed to get over there
just one round very quick succession
that stopped regards thinking that it
was part of the show and then second
round went off and those people dot just
their instinct was to duck I just said
why not just go yeah there was close to
an exit so we're just in the confusion
if we had gone plans we would have
instantly you know on to the street we
the first people open building just
confused we're on right ended up seeing
in a room that
and what we found the door to the cellar
which we just brought into it and
realize we were we were trapped and with
emotional we under there and Stephanie's
of the air at the door burst open and we
just thought come
it was two other points upwards which we
managed to walk the door and it's just
by ourselves and others were not so
lucky these are just some of the faces
of those killed mainly young and from
all over the world now Hema Gonzalez was
a 23 year old design student from Los
Angeles she's the first American
confirmed to have been killed in the
attacks Valentin rebei was the first
victim to be named the 26 year old
French lawyer graduated from the London
School of Economics he was described by
colleagues as a wonderful personality
a sturdy Akita was the cousin of the
French international footballer Lassana
Diarra on Twitter he said she was a big
sister to him Nick Alexander was from
Colchester in Essex he was killed at the
battle clan theatre where he was selling
merchandise for the band who were
performing his girlfriend tweeted you
are and always will be the love of my
life what I heard is that he died saving
life of another human being and that's I
think the act that all of us wonder if
we be brave enough to do it's tragic but
it's also or inspiring and you know I
don't think anyone knows if they'd be
strong enough to do that until it
happens Parisians wanted to know who was
responsible for the mass casualties of
Friday night and links have already been
made to neighboring Belgium this is a
poor suburb of Brussels the man being
arrested is one of three taken in a raid
believed to be linked to the attack
investigators are slowly piecing
together a picture of the eight men who
caused murderous chaos
police believe they found a Syrian
passport next to the body of one of the
stab de France attackers he's been named
in the passport as ahmed al mohammed
police say he passed into serbia last
month as part of the wave of migrants
entering europe via Greece another
attacker has been named by a French
Member of Parliament as Ishmael
Omar must FA he was identified by
fingerprints taken from the Bataclan
theatre where he blew himself up he was
a 29 year old French citizen with a
criminal record Mustafa had been flagged
as a radical Islamist but never linked
to terrorism before a French judicial
official says muster phase father and
other family members are being
questioned
an Egyptian passport was also found near
the remains of another suspected
attacker until a couple of years ago
Ishmael Mustafa lived in this
neighborhood just outside Paris France
is coming to terms with the fact that at
least one of its own citizens was
involved in the attacks look when I said
of you i knew him by sight my
sister-in-law he lives near his house
was taking care of my children i brought
my children here and I saw him dozens of
times and there were no problems
homegrown terrorists have struck before
police will be trying to find out if
there are links to the three days of
terror that shook Paris in January the
city is still hurting from the multiple
attacks which left 17 people dead 12 of
them were shot at the offices of the
satirical magazine Charlie Hebdo there
were hostages then as well at a kosher
supermarket in the east of the city
some believe Paris got back to its
casual way of life - easily
others say people have been let down by
the government they failed to anticipate
this attack and will have to understand
why this happened and correct whatever
went wrong and what went wrong went
wrong big time the second item is a very
difficult one and that is the level of
sophistication and expertise of this
attack is really rather scared because
they combined shooting suicide attacks
mass hostage taking a mixture of Bombay
and Moscow if I can if I can put it that
right this I think people were not
really expecting here on the defensive
Frances president says his country is
now at war with Islamic state the group
has claimed responsibility for the
attacks
blaming France for bombing is in Syria
it was a deliberate organized and
planned act of war we are working to
establish all the facts it's an
absolutely barbaric act
there's been international support for
the people of Paris a real sense of
global revulsion that such brutality
could visit ordinary citizens simply
enjoying a night out in such a beautiful
city my message to the French people is
simple nous somme Solidaire avec vous
new song - source longer we stand with
you
United over the weekend the floral
tributes outside Licari on bar have
grown and grown
covering the pavement where two nights
ago people they shot and injured
why asks this woman
they can understand an attack on a
high-profile landmark like a football
stadium but this was just a local
neighborhood bar Charlie a blue shooting
they were like targeting some people
precisely like journalists of course so
you feel the danger but you didn't feel
too endangered now it's like watching
you meet everybody
it's it's really strange to think about
that with my Smike affair with the dead
bodies around and you feel like all
along Paris is in a strange situation a
state of emergency has been announced
across France and 1,500 military
personnel drafted into the French
capital with fears that some of the
gunmen may still be on the run Paris is
in lockdown Parisians have been told not
to gather in large crowds but they
couldn't stay away from the city's
famous plaster la république to write
messages of defiance against those who
want to break their spirit even though
it's forbidden to be together in a
public place yeah I think that's great I
don't know we just feel very sad
but you know what we are French and
we're going to set up and fight for our
rights we are proud of for liberty of
freedom and equality for everyone I was
very upset of course I mean who could
not be upset it's just
[Music]
on Friday night football fans leaving
the stud de France sang the national
anthem La Marseillaise digging deep to
show the Solidarity needed to get
through a weekend
Parisians will never forget it
[Applause]
[Music]